- If you are Googling about diet,
understand that even though
it's the information age,
I call it the misinformation age.
- My name is LeeAnn Weintraub.
I'm a registered dietician in Los Angeles.
- My name is Kevin Libby.
I'm a nutritionist for PH2 Nutrition.
- And I provide nutrition
counseling and consulting services
to adults, families,
businesses, and organizations.
- Today, we're gonna be
answering Googled questions
about diet.
- Registered dieticians like myself
are food and nutrition experts
but we're not always big fans of diets.
Diets often don't work,
people fail at diets,
and then, there's this kind of sad feeling
of failure that comes along with that.
- The word diet in general.
It's got a connotation to
it that is like, you know,
people have to deal with restriction.
And I have my own saying,
it's not about restriction,
it's about consistency.
- So, my approach is more
of a lifestyle approach
that focuses on balance, portion control,
eating healthy nutrient-dense whole food.
If you're following a
diet and you're wondering
if you can have a cheat day, the answer is
- Maybe.
The leaner you are, the
bigger cheat you can have.
The heavier you are, the
more it's a bad idea.
- I would actually recommend look at more
like a splurge meal.
So a meal once a week, maybe twice
where you're kind of
looking forward to that,
maybe indulging in something
that's a little bit off your plan.
I would say you wanna
be careful with that.
There's benefits to a lot
of the healthy food groups
like grains, like dairy products.
And unless you have a food
allergy or a food sensitivity,
most of us need these healthy food groups
for the micronutrients and the
macronutrients that we need.
- If you remove carbohydrates,
you'll deplete glycogen storage.
Your body will be forced
to utilize fat for fuel
but you can't under-calorie.
You don't wanna restrict
calories too much.
- You wanna think about
maybe getting the right
amount for your body
which often involves portion control
and cutting back the excess.
- In America, we've overstated
protein way too much.
Concentrated proteins
will still spike insulin.
- Your body needs a balance
of all the macronutrients.
The amount of calories,
carbohydrates, protein and fats
that you need in your daily nutrition plan
really varies from person to person.
- It's not just protein.
You have to break down the tissue
by working out really, really hard
with really heavy weight
but you also need carbohydrate
to fuel the training.
- And it's not the same for everybody.
So you want to focus on a
plan that works for you.
And speaking with an expert
such as a registered dietician
or your physician is gonna
give you the best approach
and the best advice that you
need to reach your goals.
- So we just answered
the questions about diet.
So the most important thing
to take away from this is
- It's all about making
healthy, balanced eating choices
that make sense for your
lifestyle and your body.
- We wanna go organic, we wanna
stay away from refined oils,
we wanna stay away from GMOs.
- These are really important things
to get the right answer on
and we know that Google
doesn't have all the answers.
And if you meet with an expert,
you get information and advice
that's customized to you.
- Don't overthink it, you know,
people are way too obsessed with it.
Don't sweat the petty stuff
and don't pet the sweaty stuff.
(upbeat music)